hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's - now this videos a little late
and I'm sorry for that unfortunately
chica my puppy was playing in the mud in
the front yard after it rained last
night and it was an interesting little
story arc I've got some pictures it went
from she was so excited that she got to
play in the mud oh boy I can't wait to
tell you all about it dad
- immediately when I take her inside and
put a swim cap on Oh what did I do
I'm so sorry I didn't mean to make you
mad - then going once we got in the
shower oh it's just a bath oh it's okay
thanks so much this is great I love my
life so that was my adventure with chica
this morning and now I get to play with
other animals that want to put harm on
me in some way but I'm gonna be fine I
can get through this night - very
quickly but then once it gets to night
three and they start adding more and
more I have a funny feeling I'm not
going to do goood Shh okay so yeah we
are we already know how this is gonna go
so I just need to pay attention through
this night and then get to the end
because that's okay one of the reasons
that I get so easily worked in five
nights at freddys is because I have this
late in Fira I have this fear of
animatronics I forget what the actual
scientific term is but so whenever I go
into a store and I see like store
mannequins it just makes my skin crawl
like the same thing with like the
reaction to trip to phobia I think I've
said that before but just for clarity's
sake I don't like animatronics they're
weird and they shouldn't move and it's
just bizarre how are you back already
that's convenient anyway I'll get
through this night okay one thing that I
always liked about this particular fan
five nights at Freddy's fan game is that
this one has a lot of polish and I don't
even know what I'm trying to be quiet
here this one has a lot of polish I
don't want them to come find me in the
darkness but this one does like it's
it's well crafted there's a lot of
things to like about the smoothness of
the transitions the detail in the
backgrounds and stuff like that that
that that is really impressive because
it shows that they actually gave a [ __ ]
and
oftentimes that's my baseline for a good
games just the developers giving a [ __ ]
and that's like really good feature a
great feature I forgot to turn that off
that's okay it's not necessary right now
wait what is that that's sketch the
middle one on the left side I haven't
seen that am atrani before so I don't
know what that is
it's weird oh why is it gonna be scary
why do you gotta make good scary that's
not cool bruh not cool oh boy what
nightmare am I gonna be living now yeah
uh-huh okay cool am I gonna be unlocking
another horror
return return what to where do I get
overturn something to that box or do I
got to return the horrible monster
that's a monkey arm on the ground one of
300 this is my job
oh my job is to pick up the dismembered
body parts of all that have been dead if
I'd in here and identify I got me
murdered that's another word it's common
colloquialism in my town why why why are
Joe Joe's body parts strewn all about
this place okay there's gonna think well
I'll be right back
I got to drop them off in the box first
apparently Oh got the second piece which
is the leg and I noticed that the torso
was already in the bow oh god you're not
you the dorsal was already in the box
but this is what I mean by when I say
polish like this is this is cool this is
obviously this is inspired by the I'm
just gonna see where the last body part
is so I know I could save myself some
time but like this is what I mean this
is polish right here this is well
crafted okay I'll come get you in a
second there buddy but this is
well-crafted it's well-made its
well-designed it's it's it's it's it's
cool even though it's absolutely
horrifying but it's cool it's like
horrifying in the connotation that I'm
existing in the same building that
whatever pulled apart this animatronic
and I don't even feel much for these
animatronics I don't know why I'm upset
that this thing is torn shreds is I
think it's just cuz Jojo never really
bothered me in the first place judge'
was always cool my book and that
horrifying Oh
I don't like that that's the opposite oh
yeah I just balance it on the ear on top
of your head
that's a lot of talent that you got
there Pangu but you know still a little
concerned about what's gonna happen when
I try to put them all together I mean
this Pangu like the puppet I see the
life giver of all these animatronics man
is someone gonna theorycraft the origins
of Pangu boy we did it we did it
Pangu made the era Joe Joe made the
horrible mistake of trying to unleash
whatever monstrosity was inside that
closet he was just trying to be a nice
dude and then Radhika's must have
sprinted out and torn him to shreds oh
by the way just yesterday during the
grumps scream I opened up my direct
messages on Twitter and that was a
horrifying mistake I was getting like
30,000 messages I was on the the game
grumps charity stream just yesterday and
it went really really well he went
amazingly well thank you to everyone who
donated but oh god was gonna have a high
oh oh oh there's a good Oh God
sastra faithlyn's get your sass out of
your ass we need we all got those in
wrong one you oh [ __ ] shut that one up
get on deck oh god I didn't know that
that's was the thing that was gonna
happen oh my god that's not okay
Oh what are you doing here candy I don't
have time for you oh god no no no Frick
dick oh I'm so boned start off already
start up oh this got much harder and
immediately oh my goodness okay so woof
woof woof woof woof bellboy a Magi I'm
gonna die oh hello okay there you are
haha I I successfully avoided you so
what I need to do if I see Pangu I'm
immediately just gonna flip it down or
flip do another one
oh boy someone over there yet OOP Oh
Nelly that's got a lot more complicated
very quickly something they're not okay
go away okay we're good we're good we're
good there's gonna be a lot of
flip-flopping here I do not like that
Pangu you are a son of a [ __ ] although
you are a nice guy I bet in spirit
although I pretty sure spirit is all he
got left at this point after all the end
we're trying to rip your soul out of
your body a million times over
fine I'll forgive you for now [ __ ] I
wasn't paying attention I think it's
okay at this point they're gonna be
ripping them out of the walls
willy-nilly but I think they recover
quick enough somehow they automatically
repair I mean if it's one thing that the
animatronics have lives of their own it
it's not too much to understand that the
phones would also be alive and ready to
murder so I think the UI Oh
oh gosh Oh golly gosh I think the
effective strategy is just keep them
bouncing around different places so that
you don't you don't stay stay in one
place for too long and then they stay
mobile sorry I'm getting a little antsy
okay he's there
cool oh boy okay he's gonna move yet wow
that was fast
whoa that's fast hi Cindy
oh oh oh that was close
oh that was really close honk for lark
yay it's not even a honk anymore it's
more the squeaky squonk
okay that was unconvenient cuz if if the
phone gets disabled in a place where the
monkey Jojo is a bang bong and then I'm
gonna be like far no that's not right
oh [ __ ] that's not right oh god see
exactly what I didn't want exactly what
I didn't want come alive Oh wake me up
inside [ __ ] okay rokay everything is
fine even though everything is obviously
not fine I'm gonna I'm trying to inside
my ass am i ho ho oh god that's not good
Squiggy 4 look yeah I'm gonna die that's
not where I wanted to do that oh that's
a bang oh okay we're okay so bang bong
over there and then I'm a ding dong and
phone off and then you're gonna go [ __ ]
yourself okay we got it game face on
[ __ ] I believe in the heart of the cards
I believe the heart of the mark I
believe in tiny box still and probably
believe it no oh that's the opposite of
what I wanted to happen oh man I lied
all sunshine and rainbows to be blasting
out of my ass but this is the opposite
that's too much I can't handle it my
fragile psyche it's uncapable my sanity
meter is real oh so this is just
pressing the buttons a little too hard
to the point where I turn that off I
don't have time to readjust my
headphones goddamn it get out of here
seeing the candy I don't even know what
your name is anymore
yeah you've raised very disappear at the
last second not better turn these off
the right brow over here time God that
scared me every time he pops up is that
a banging oh I thought that was a
banging but I predicted it into the
future because I got some sort of vision
for that it's the only way to be 2020
2020 mode and Annie gives these games oh
my god
my heart is like racing a million miles
an hour I'm not capable of handling
stressful situation like this even
though it's just a stupid video game I'm
not okay oh God thank you
Oh 5:00 a.m. please just let me finish I
just wanted to be over goddamn it oh
wait no callback callback go back redial
there's a little bit longer I can't
believe I've already gone through five
hours of this [ __ ] and this is only nice
eh what's that for five yeah be like oh
god stop bagging
where the hell's Pangu go I know he's
gonna be showing his dumb ass up anytime
in and out no I don't even know I'm
saying words anymore but I'm trying to
colloquial enunciate it's right word I
couldn't think of the right word I'm too
much thinking about what I'm doing here
this is all new this is all new to me
somebody you may have already played
this game but it's new to me I'm going
so crazy I think I'm hearing phones
ringing when they're not ringing that
it's ringing there I know it's [ __ ] you
okay but I'm almost done and it's almost
okay stop don't do that just go to the
back corner and everything's gonna be
fine
this night has not been okay what this
night has been a wild ride I will tell
you what oh there we go
Oh got it nailed it all right now let's
get through this animatronic nightmare
and we'll be on our way tonight for I
imagine things are only gonna get better
for me I know that for a man I know that
for a fact to collect oh no I'm blank
why am i blank oh boy here we go
and space new candy Cindy they look like
the old candy Cindy but I'm not 100%
sure if that was intentional oh man do I
just have the back of my head exposed
like that I mean I say me I'm obviously
an animatronic douchenozzle that doesn't
know what he's doing and kind of wants
to murder security guards no matter what
where is Chester who's
Chester Chester the cheetah Chester
cheezy Chester
oh man who's he the mouse might have
been the mouse I mean once again that
music is exceptionally comforting and
I'm super happy that that's pumping up
over the stereos oh god damn it I didn't
read what that was
I'll freeze-frame ensue you guys can see
it but dangit wait a min 1991 it was it
was 1989 before is this two years later
wait a minute hang on I got to go back
and look at the dates there because that
calendar definitely changed cuz it
wasn't 91 before I'm I'm almost positive
this would be a long time between our
band who's on the left oh okay I thought
it was gonna come at me okay alright
then
so that's a sign three two and three you
get a bonus night but we'll get tonight
for real soon thank you everybody so
much for watching
wish me luck and being a single dad to
three children the two boys and chica
and sometimes Lego so thank you
everybody so much for watching we'll get
to this game again real soon and as
always I will see you in the next video
that presen off don't worry here in this
town Pelican Bay we don't have busy
boundaries